do you ever feel pressured to be more
like a stereotype instead of just who
you are do you ever feel pressured when
you go in for an audition or are you
actually you got the park and they say
you know what can you tweak this and do
it a little different and you feel that
your pressure yeah you know the pressure
is is that you want to work right and so
you want to please the people right that
the producer the director and so you
know there is that I'm gonna swallow my
pride on this one and let me go in here
and you know even though I know that
that is maybe so stereotypical that is
not even based in reality but it's kind
of what they want and you always have
that I always call it that look in the
mirror moment you know it's before he's
waiting you're waiting to go on set and
you know they're doing your makeup you
finish and you're sitting there and
you're sitting there and you're like you
know you get ready to go on and you're
like that's Jesus Christ man I got it
really you know do I really have to do
this or but you know you want you want
you want to work because every actor in
LA is you know wants to work and so
sometimes you kind of have to swallow
your pride a little bit but it is part
of the distastefulness of it makes the
business a little distasteful I mean I
know a lot of actors and directors very
talented super talented that I just
don't get their opportunity because in
some cases maybe they're not willing
they're not willing to to do that I deal
with that pretty much you know every
every week as an actor you know in terms
of the way I take my photographs in
terms of the way I present myself I'm
always feeling like maybe I'm not
finding as much success as I want or
that I'm not getting as many
opportunities as I want because me
personally I tend to have a more of a
rebellious kind of a stubborn Flair
about me you know and so that's great
you know as a person I think a lot of my
friends appreciate
sort of Who I am but oftentimes I feel
like well maybe I should just play into
the fact that you know I'm no matter who
I am I walk in they're gonna see an
Asian you know kid you know who's not
extraordinarily good-looking not not too
tall not too big he's just sort of a
normal kid and and I'm I'm not gonna get
to be the the hero the action hero or or
whatever you know and so sometimes I do
think about how to not play into the
stereotype but but but embrace things
that you can't change about yourself and
embrace the fact that we're often making
you know movies and TV for for people
who are not as well-versed about
diversity or they don't care about that
topic or whatever I was talking to my
6-4 professor and she told me that she's
like don't listen to those people
because I had someone tell me you're not
the engine newtype and you're not gonna
be able to play that you should probably
stick to the characters I have somebody
to tell me that specifically that way
and he wasn't like he complains these
characters just you never play the
unsure news so when I was in Shakespeare
class and then we will peak out
monologues from a play I would always go
for the characters I would never go for
the leads and my professor was like why
don't why didn't you pick that that
would be better for you and I was like
well I'm not really the leading lady I
can just play the character a lot better
and I would have fun with that and I
feel comfortable with that you know she
was like nothing you need to you need to
get the leading lady and she would hand
me that monologue and it would that
would be the stretch for me and all of a
sudden a whole new world of characters
would open up for me and she would look
at me be like oh okay now we can give
you this one as well and all of a sudden
should start handing me their leading
ladies and I was like but but I'm not
supposed to play that you know in my
head I got stuck to that concept and
that was the biggest shock for me that
was the biggest
little bubble of the actor that says oh
my gosh you're opening new worlds for me
that I don't know if I'm comfortable
with that that was my taking me out of
my comfort zone that they put me in does
that make sense
that was the biggest place that I felt
shocked as and I felt like I was
stretching beyond even the limits I felt
like I could go to I feel a bit insulted
when someone talks to me or you reading
something and I was reading for this
feature movie and you should be the thug
you know you wait you should be like
wait a minute I have more to my
character than that
you know it's more but I know that's
just they're thinking that because of
whatever social ideas that have been
ingrained in our heads they just
automatically flip that switch
oh you're you should be the thug or you
should be you should be robbed the
robber or you you should be someone
who's negative and I'm it really kind of
turns you the wrong way but at the same
time you have to realize that you know
you have to be able to communicate with
people and say listen you know what I
could play that role as a robber or as a
thug but why don't I try this of the
character let's see what what happens if
I do this character you know so you have
to be subtle and you have to be you have
to be really professional and director
acts can you beware get out and I was
like okay sure
and of course you know I'm from
Washington DC so inner city so I can go
there in portray these characters but
that's so not who I am and I always
think it's more comfortable to add a
little spice of who I am into it I won't
even submit for things that and I feel
lack of a better word like the loud
sassy neighbor or whatever that you see
in a lot of african-american films and
TV and it's kind of hard because you
don't want to like say okay that's just
bad you
you know because there's lots of people
that do that work but I always thought
even in my personal life with with as an
african-american not being either black
enough or being just too articulate if
that makes sense and that's ridiculous I
know because what else would I be but I
if I see anything that's slated like an
extreme of who I should be as a black
person or as an african-american I won't
even submit because I I don't agree with
that and I wouldn't feel good at the end
of the day presenting myself in that
regard even as a character because it's
unless it was justified artistically or
if it meant something or if it was like
the way the journey of the character I
just I just don't I don't agree with it
so I wouldn't even submit myself and
I've never been put in it box so far
thankfully for me as an artist I feel
like you should put a bit of yourself in
it so when someone or a director tells
me to tell it tell it to me to tone it
down it's hard because you want to
follow your gut but then at the same
time you're like he's a director he's my
boss I got to do what he says so it's
like I try to sneak it in a bit because
I mean what's the meaning of it artists
and artist is being who you truly are so
I know you have to portray the character
but and a part of me still says just put
a bit a bit of you in it you know what I
mean I'm from West Africa I was I've
never lived in a country long enough to
call it my home in that sense I was born
in Sierra Leone that lived there for
five years the war broke out I moved to
Senegal Europe and Canada so I'm moving
to the States last year I found that
every time people it's ok have I put
this basically when people see me or
casting them to see me they say ok she's
gonna play the best ghetto girl or
she'll be gonna go but then the minute I
opened my mouth and started speaking
it's like whoa what's going on so I
don't have that you know that accent I
can play a gentle girl only comedic but
I can't do a serious like you know what
up kind of thing like I had do it as a
joke so you can't take me
seriously so I I try to stay away from
those roles where they're like we need a
girl who's Urban's go through some you
knows from the South or something I
can't I can't do it really because first
I just I try to connect to that but it
doesn't really work for me and as an
actor I know I should be open-minded to
that but I will work on that when it
comes down to down the road but for now
I'm just going to perfect what I'm good
at which is the comedic and you know the
serious upscale I guess people a lot of
people call me the the Kerry Washington
type or the Gabrielle Union type that's
the types that I've been told I relate
to like the younger version of that
because of the way I pulled myself on
the way I speak I'm from Calexico and
growing up in the border town
I was literally next to the fence and a
lot of these rows are my best friends
they're people I grew up with you know
my neighbors my family the irony is that
I never I never had you know a very
linear you know part of this because I
made up we bring in you know because of
God because my grandmother raised me I
wanted to be there for my you know set a
good example for my my two brothers but
yet I take on these these rose and and
yes they've asked me to do that and I
would tell them that's not that we you
know they're portrayed in real life and
so there's that you know that that
conversation right and then at the end
of the day we would you know come to
agreement but it just wouldn't be
natural for me to you know portray them
such a decision away but at the same
time I want to you know please the the
casting director or the director so you
know there's a there's a you know
balance that we have just because I try
not to let it get to me I guess it's
different I wanted
I mean some of them of the days when I
look like at audition notices I'm just
like I wish you know I were more that
stereotype or I wish I were more that
mythos tea and I wish you know I was
fitting or I could fit in that category
and then um other days I'm just really
proud of Who I am but yeah it gets those
days I get fewer and fewer and what's
happening I've been into auditions like
we didn't even know you had tattoo it
was perfect
share your tattoos like doesn't he
looked in his like wow like I just went
from being like auditioning from
innocent David you know little guy down
the street so now I must be like the
bully in the in the whole production
because I had tattoos once again just
that stereotype forcing me and some plan
of character that I'm like I said once
again have no issue plan because I do
understand as actor you're acting but
once again you do want to play David
some other times where or the doctor or
the lawyer or you know the general
versus your same stereotypical low
rankings in the in the and the
production parts you know you know I
will play a wonderful principal but I
understand also in this traditional
society in Hollywood there's you know
the normative look and once again I feel
once once we break those barriers of the
that normative look you know you're
gonna get to see so many different type
of talents from so many different type
of people it's just everywhere literally
once we just like stop just living in a
close-minded my frame will see so much
in life will gets appreciate and
understand so many different type of
people characters roles everything when
I look at like casting casting notices
for you know certainly kill projects
that's going on in LA
I was looking at some before like
thinking of myself like could I play
this character yes you know it's like
looking for hard teenager to play like
in a gang he's you know he's big poor
and he's like really blah blah blah you
know there's so much about like these
hard urban character and I was like
thinking like if if I walked into the
audition do I need a dress like that
just so they can see past like how I
would normally present myself an
audition would they be able to see past
like how I look to portray that
character so yeah I think sometimes I do
feel pressured that I need to like be
kind of extreme just to get noticed even
though I am very confident my talents
and abilities a night as an actor I feel
like sometimes like image plays so much
it's like what you're able to be cast in
just from that first interaction with
the casting director just the regular
normal guy like you know hang out have a
beer wedding doesn't cheat on his wife
and doesn't you know beat his kids or
abuses kids know those roles don't go to
african-american guys in a draw and the
drama maybe in a sitcom but it's always
funny like but never just like hey it's
just a normal there's a normal guy like
the guy you have a beer with you know
while you're watching the game on Sunday
and there's not enough for those roles
it's just you know he's an accountant I
said he's not ladies no you didn't he
know you didn't play sports in college
he wasn't a basketball player he's got
his degree in accounting in the guy you
know owns the accounting company or
never happens know I hope that changes
but I don't know so I do think that
there are ways that you can navigate
this whole journey you can still do with
dignity you can still kind of be who you
are you know so I you know I mean I said
I I I struggle with that all the time
in terms of who I am to the market you
know and who I am as a person and you
know like what is the balance
you